hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
Rachel Jay King you can follow her on
Twitter you can of course catch her on
the Schmo down one day I'll be versing
her in the Oscar movies category I'm
gonna beat her ass with guessing
multiple choices that's what I'm gonna
do come on
who won the Oscar for Best Actor in 1984
that's not a fair question
you don't know not at the top of my head
not by year Wow Mickey worth ear the
dragon Michael Douglas black where your
watch the trailer for this movie called
breaking in which is directed by James
make me to make McTavish yep wow that's
a lot easier to say who is directed V
for Vendetta ninja assassin directed
episodes of Marco Polo and sensei
yep oh yeah yeah he's her best bud and I
always doing this movie with Gabrielle
Union it's on the trending page I only
had a few it's January
[Music]
a whole playlist she's playing bombs now
I know where are you selling it that's
what you do when someone passes away
check it out
fully automate security system windows
have retractable shields this place is a
fortress
[Music]
like I just they're breaking it nice
Gabrielle
interesting you are do exactly what I
say or you and your kids will not
survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mom you have no clue what
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
seriously that's the best part about
this she does look badass it kind of
reminds me of a slight reverse situation
of panic room yes exactly I love the
idea of her being on the outside and her
having to be the one to break in yes
nice the one breaking egg yeah there's
the the white man you know that trailer
kind of delightfully surprised me yeah
because this feels like you can go one
of two ways
it could be surprisingly entertaining
right or it could be really awful it's
actually good yeah regardless it looks
like it's gonna be entertained
I agree yeah completely that's always a
plus for me in any book yeah like they
don't all have to be oscar-winning
screeches be fun like they said like
from the producers and movies like
obsessed and all those movies are fun
they're not great I mean it's not the
producers of no good deed in the movie
obsessed which are these movies that
star a friggin American people and they
have these very familiar plots while
they the rod tomatoes might not be like
they're the greatest films in the world
they still really do appeal to like the
african-american community and they do
really well because there's a fourth
like I said like a bit of a formula to
it but what I liked about this one it
sort of looks like it flips the formula
exactly yeah looks like it's sort of
just adding to it because movies are a
ton of fun like we were talking about
not asker winners but like enjoyable on
the edge of your seat a little bit of a
three yeah type situation going into
this trailer I did not think I was gonna
I'm really happy with everything that's
been going on with you know whatever you
want to call it the feminist movement or
whatever that's been happening and
especially in the entertainment industry
within the past year and sometimes I
feel like it's a little bit they're kind
of taking advantage of it sometimes I
don't know how to put it without
sounding like I'm a good suit because
I'm not totally for it as the shredder
was going I realized I am gung ho for
all the feminists
in here black actress mother Mother's
Day like the capitalizing on all right
now no I'm for it a badass single mom
saving the day why not let's go for it
no idea what a mother is capable of
doing yeah I could believe that and
Billy Crudup as a bad guy not Billy
Crudup back does name all I know is the
dad Billy and he's the bad guy he's the
bad guy in Drive Angry Billy Burke damn
sure got that jean-claude Van Damme won
the Oscar though for kick box that was a
delightful surprise good to see
Gabrielle Union back I haven't seen her
things since an episode of friend she
was in once watches here again you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell
Rachel Jay King is on Twitter
twitter.com slash Rachel Jay King I
follow her so you should too because she
is awesome and her tweets are
motivational or poignant poignant
poignant say the G right technically you
don't say it poignant why didn't realize
this Rodin was also a spelling
competition to try to be pointed I don't
know if I succeed that often mmm
it's either that or I complain about
certain movies in certain studio moves
I've been known to do that - yeah it's
like personal development talk sure yeah
yeah like the next Tony Robbins oh yeah
that's me or Joyce Myers
alright